let's read this first story from the
hill
stocks plunge
as rising oil wheat prices shake market
stocks fell sharply monday as the
economic fault of russia's war in
ukraine rattled investors the dow jones
industrial average fell almost 800
points monday to close the loss of 2.4
percent companies in the finance travel
entertainment retail and construction
industries fell sharply monday as
skyrocketing oil prices raised fears of
an economic slowdown while energy
companies rallied on the prospect of
higher prices that's kind of messed up
but uh yeah u.s gas prices average hits
new record high the previous being set
in 2008. so uh i saw some people in the
chat they were saying doom cast irl uh
are we just uh
are we just preaching the apocalypse i
mean we didn't make any of this up yeah
it's not like but these stories i think
it's it is a question of what you choose
to focus on and i think sometimes the
show can get a little bit dark but this
is all true it's valid to talk about it
i don't think it's the apocalypse i i
think it is definitely the economy
crumbling like the federal reserve's
fiat currency system is just coming to
an end or some sort of trans
transmutation
yeah no or a great reset it's not yeah i
don't think it's the apocalypse either
well whether or not it's a great reset
it's up to you tim it's good to be aware
though right it's good to be aware of it
yeah i mean i don't know i kind of you
know i feel like
when you go on
major news sources
i'm not just the only one talking about
this is what everyone is talking about
you know when i look at what's what's
happening on twitter when i look when i
when i go to like cultural websites
sure they're talking about other stuff
too but like somehow this stuff still
finds its way into the mix like it's not
just a movie something's happening
politically that involves it and i
wonder if the issue is because we talked
about this before with gamergate
that because you can't write video game
news every single day it's only so many
stories you can write about a new video
game they inject politics into it so it
could be that's why politics has become
so prominent but i kind of feel like i
don't know russia invaded a country and
there's like war happening so
well i think it's possible that maybe
we're just talking about this before
everyone else was i think that we've
been talking about this probably longer
than a lot of these other people when we
started to see the news articles come
out that were kind of in agreement with
what we were saying we were kind of like
oh look at this it's really happening
other people really think this so it's
great to be aware of and i feel like
it's part of keeping people informed
just try to stay positive i guess when
uh i think it was alex alex jones for
sure maybe the first time he came in
with michael malus it might have been
the second time and he was like it's
klaus schwab klaus schwab's the guy and
i was like i never heard this name
before i was like what's that who's that
and he started telling us and he told us
and now it's to the point where like jp
sears releases a video four or five days
ago about the great reset cloud schwab
blackrock to the heart of the matter
half a million views and it's like
mainstream now so that's a good sign
yeah lindsay's on it james lindsay just
keeps posting the same paint brush meme
of klaus schwab saying something stupid
yeah i don't i don't you know look
there's uh some billionaires saying that
world war iii is coming and i guess
we'll talk about that everybody drink i
said it
drink something healthy i'm wondering if
when you look at like
the price is skyrocketing inflation
there some articles are warning
inflation could hit double digits and
i'm kind of like by what metric because
if we're going by the same calculation
as the 80s inflations in the double
digits
so it kind of feels like if you did want
a great reset a war is a great way to go
about doing it is it possible that the
pandemic wasn't quite enough for it
because it felt like that was a really
strong step toward that i don't know
what he said
i think they're trying to destroy the
economy intentionally and i think
inevitably we're
yeah i would say double digits for
inflation i i could definitely see that
happening and i think that uh the
pandemic was probably
something that they were using to start
it and i think a lot of people are
falling off of that bandwagon now so now
war yeah the media says you're a
conspiracy theorist for saying that even
though wasn't it didn't klaus schwab
write a book called coven 19 in the
great reset or something yeah yeah these
people are out in the open and that's
the thing it's like they're so open
about what their plans are and you're
still labeled the conspiracy theory for
just literally repeating what they're
saying that's the crazy thing no exactly
who are they convincing are they like
people just trapped in the matrix who
believe it i guess there are some people
but at the end of the day it doesn't
really matter whether you believe it
what matters is whether you're willing
to go along with what they're saying i'm
not sure that they're really interested
in true believers so much as they're
interested in you not saying anything
when you do see through the narrative i
think that would be fine if no one
believed them but everyone was too
afraid to say anything man how
conspiratorial should we get i don't
know i mean
like what does conspiracy theory even
mean anymore georgia guys
that's pretty there are certain examples
there are certain examples of conspiracy
theories which are like so completely
over the line and insane sounding that
you don't even really need the label
conspiracy theory in order to understand
that they're ridiculous like when people
start talking about flat earth yeah but
then when it comes to things like the
lab leak hypothesis
and it turns out that it's true it's
like well then the term conspiracy
theory didn't even fit there right and
so i find the term is almost always used
either a where it doesn't apply or b
isn't needed i like that conspiracy like
can we just talk about conspiracy yeah
but what happened
conspiracy implies a criminal plot right
yes that's why it's stupid like hollow
earth and flat earth there's not a
conspiracy right like there's no cabal
of elites who are like we will make sure
the earth is free
i think their argument is it's the cabal
that convinces us that it's spherical
when it's not i see
they call it what do they say that
you're a globulist
that's a flat arthritis called populist
globulin because you can't they can't
call you a globalist because that's a
different word but it's gotten so
twisted to the point where when i said
there was no conspiracy between donald
trump and russia i was a conspiracy
theorist
yeah when i said that the russian
government was not controlling the
executive branch
i was a conspiracy theorist right isn't
that insane that doesn't mean anything
they want to new york times won a bunch
of awards didn't they for the ukraine
thing for reporting on uh russiagate
claiming that you know donald trump was
secretly colluding with the russians and
they get they i don't think they said
that explicitly because if they did
there'd be bigger news but they did
investigations into like trump's ties
with like russia and they win awards and
everyone's like oh and they're all
clapping like you're so smart and then
you know
the the mueller report comes out and
it's like
none of that happened you won awards for
doing nothing yeah well
none of them lose the awards right no
walter durrante didn't even lose his uh
pulitzer for covering up the hall
anymore right you know you know what i
said i'm like
someone someone the response from a lot
of people because russiagate was wrong
they were like well they still did good
reporting and that's why they won the
awards and i'm like listen what if i if
i hire a guy to mow my lawn and i go
inside and when i come outside he mowed
my neighbor's lawn i'm gonna be like sir
you worked really hard you did a bang-up
job but that's not my grass right so you
expect me to pay you nah it's not
happening like they did the work they
just did the wrong work so i don't know
what it is you want me to say but it's
just it's hilarious when the
establishment gives itself awards that's
all i think any time i see any of these
ceremonies i'm like oh you patented
yourself on the back there what a
surprise
yeah but you know what's weird is that
there used to be that we used to have
like a mono culture we used to have one
award you know we would not we had all
these award ceremonies and everyone was
just like turning the tv on and watching
everyone turning the tv tv on and
watching super bowl now it's like you
know i was reading about uh joe biden's
state of the union having like the
lowest ratings of any state union in 30
years and i'm like yeah it's because
people are on the internet you know no
one's watching on tv but more
importantly a million like one point
something million people watch steven
crowder's version of the state of the
union where he's correcting them right
and then we had like 750k vod views on
us nice drinking
drinking our way through yeah so you
have a lot of people who don't like joe
biden who would rather watch us make fun
of them or correct them and so basically
of all these different pockets of
different cultural cultural spheres of
influence
and then
i don't know culture war chaos in
fighting but what brings us back to the
exact reason why they need to use the
term conspiracy theory so much because
information is more widely accessible
and they can't hide it from you but they
can make you embarrassed to repeat any
of the information that you heard and
that's what that label is for it's right
and weird yeah yeah it's just a
deflection tactic just don't care what's
the uh that's exactly what it is you
have to not care because of what you're
saying is legitimate if what you're
saying is legitimately crazy it doesn't
matter whether you get called a
conspiracy theorist you sound crazy
georgia guidestones i'm not familiar
i've heard a little bit about them i
haven't looked into them too deeply well
you were gonna say something no i was
gonna say but you you just made a good
point like i remember back in the day i
would watch like alien shows and you
went conspiracy theory okay cool like
you used your brain to conclude whether
or not something is true or not and you
weren't ridiculed for it but now you
can't even come up with a a a theory for
anything without being
no no this is this is why can i
respond to that really quickly
the reason is because when you're
looking at ancient aliens that's
obviously ridiculous people can look at
that and dismiss it but when you're the
only time they need to censor
misinformation is when there's a chance
some of it's true
yeah i was going to say how come ancient
aliens on the history channel gets to i
mean seriously it's some of the most
racist
racist stuff ever don't think about it
ancient aliens
i love your ancient aliens you're a fun
show but when you have like these white
european professors i know sit down in
front of a camera and say there's no
possible way south american indigenous
could build structures like this it had
to be alien that's so true i'm like oh
my gosh like we just can't figure it out
i think he's like aliens
well it's like ancient rome that
concrete that could set under water and
they're like well of course
but those people in in south america nah
they couldn't have figured anything out
it had the only logical explanation how
they built things was aliens
i'm like i'm like how is that not very
racist
i got some information about conspiracy
theories from wikipedia the term
conspiracy theory is itself the subject
of a conspiracy theory which claims the
term was popularized by the cia in order
to discredit conspiratorial believers
interesting particularly critics of the
warren commission who was like studying
the uh kennedy assassination luke said
that yeah i heard that maybe that he's
who i heard it from the cia seeded the
ideas of conspiracy theorists being a
problem when people were like trying to
figure out what happened to kennedy and
they were like no we just want to kind
of sweep it under the rug they're all
conspiracy theorists ignore them and now
the term is so crazy like you said
unless it's breaking a law it's not
really a conspiracy
is it a conspiracy to believe that
aliens like built the incan temples or
something only if it was against
thinking so
you're right like i'm sorry
i think that if you would argue that it
was a conspiracy theory because
if you were able to determine that
ancient aliens were involved here
archaeologists could determine that too
when they're covering it up i think
that's the theory like they don't want
to let these people with alternatives
and so that's why they call it a
conspiracy that's a different conspiracy
though right there's the cons there's
the the the show is literally talking
about could aliens have drawn what are
they called the mascot lines yeah those
things nazca as editors yeah where it's
like from the sky you can see these
massive pictures that are what like
hundreds of feet long so cool but from
the ground you can't see anything i'm
like maybe they had hotter balloons
i want to make a point here because you
were talking about the warren report
according to a gallup poll
the majority of americans disbelieve the
official narrative on the jfk
assassination to this day now i don't
really have a dog in this fight i
haven't looked too deeply into it but
in 1975 it was i think yeah 81 of people
said that they thought that there were
more people involved in the
assassination of jfk than were stated so
it's just interesting that in that case
you have the vast majority of people
disbelieving the official narrative
but
you're crazy if you're with them it's
just everyone else is crazy but the 20
of people who are saying yes i believe
the government they're the ones with
their their heads on straight i find
that a little bit so interesting i keep
saying georgia guidestones because yeah
what it really seems to be if you're
being charitable is that like in the 80s
a bunch of rich people
built these big stones in multiple
languages that can perform a series of
functions like there's like a sundial or
something and like some astrological
like there's like math or something i
don't know and then there's like rules
well they wanted to make sure that any
humans who came after us would have
access to certain basic knowledge
and that's what they're called the guide
stones but one of the rules is that the
population of the planet should never
exceed 500 million that's right i've
i've heard of this so the conspiracy
theory is that there are powerful global
elites that want to purge what is that
7.6 billion people or something yeah to
get us down to half a million now i
don't know if that's true because it
seems like the guide stones if you're
being charitable were just like the
height of the cold war people were
scared there's going to be nuclear
annihilation so a bunch of rich people
were like let's build these big stones
that that do these things and like if we
all die
then the people come after us we'll like
find them and be like oh we'll do that i
guess the crazy thing is to say that
population should never exceed 500
million that's so freakish like what do
you do when you hit 499 million 900 like
you just start well not the acts like
what the heck exactly well if you're in
a lead i'm telling you this you don't
commit suicide right other people have
to die right
that's crazy
yeah yeah it's crazy i agree with you
completely it's terrific who built these
things i don't know uh i don't know
turner i think ted turner was involved
in it wasn't it i don't know i'm not
sure i might have yeah you gotta you
better back that up okay sorry ted but
we don't do misinformation on this
podcast no something else so they exist
they're a real thing
and i
you know my explanation for why they
were built is i believe like the basic
explanation for why they were built but
then the more conspiratorial ideas that
there are people who want to adhere to
its rules now to prevent any kind of you
know mass extinction event in which case
there are people who think they want to
reduce the population of the planet
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you